La volta al món a peu, dia 257.
Ara he estat esmorzant amb els lituans,
que m'han fet un cafè
amb una màquina que tenen.
Ostres, quin luxe portar tant pes.
Poder portar el que vulguis.
Tecnologia.
No sé molt bé com funciona, però estava molt bo el cafè.
Ara aquí baixa una munió de gent.
No sé què van a fer.
Bé, bueno, ara són uns 60 quilòmetres fins al centre d'Uxambe
i 50 i pico fins a una mica a les afores.
Ho veig una mica complicat arribar perquè, clar,
és una mica tard, són les 8
i no vull caminar tants quilòmetres.
Per tant, probablement hauré d'acabar abans, no ho sé, ja ho veuré.
També és veritat que és això, que és tot baixada, com us vaig dir ahir.
Bueno, ha sigut una bona nit
i és curiós perquè,
l'Uxambe és la part més càlida del país.
Amb diferència, poden haver-hi 40 craus avui, no ho sé, perquè no tinc cobertura.
I aquí, que estem a tants pocs quilòmetres, 50, 60,
ha sigut una nit
fresqueta, és a dir, he pogut dormir entre el sac sense suar.
Curiós.
Let's go.
Bueno, he perdut una altra cosa.
Suma i segue, tu, que no pari la festa.
Horrible, eh?
És el pitjor.
Ni la pluja, ni el mal temps, ni la calor,
crec que el pitjor és perdre les coses.
Bueno, què he perdut aquesta vegada?
He perdut l'adaptador per carregar el rellotge, el Garmin.
És un adaptador que li poses un cable USB-C
i llavors té l'adaptador del Garmin.
Això...
A veure, què vol dir?
Què vol dir?
És difícil de reemplaçar.
Si estigués a qualsevol país occidental, no.
Però aquí a Tajikistan no hi ha cap botiga de Garmin
i no crec que molta gent tingui Garmins.
Per sort, avui o demà arribo a la capital
i, bueno, que la capital és on hi ha més possibilitats que n'hi hagi,
he estat buscant i no he trobat res per internet.
Bueno, em passejaré per algun centre comercial,
algun lloc on hi hagi botigues d'electrònica,
a veure si de xorra ho tenen.
Ja et dic, ho veig molt difícil, eh?
Ho veig, dubto molt.
Ho he estat buscant també per pàgines de segona mà de Tajikistan.
Hi havia gent que venia a Garmins, però no al cable.
Això es pot importar, val?
Però clar, trigar temps a importar i no tinc temps.
Val?
I això què vol dir?
Doncs que no podré gravar més els tracks.
Sí, sí que puc gravar.
De fet, ara he parat el rellotge perquè ja tenia poca bateria
i he engegat l'estrava a l'aplicació d'estrava.
Llavors, ho podré gravar igualment.
Suposo que gastarà més bateria.
Segur que gastarà més bateria, cosa que no m'interessa especialment al Pamir.
A veure, pot ser que estigui en algun lloc de la motxilla, val?
He buscat una mica, però no tot a la motxilla.
Pot ser que estigui en algun lloc.
És una de les coses que jo tenia més por de perdre
perquè és bastant fàcil de perdre.
És una cosa molt, molt petita
i encara prou que m'ha durat vuit mesos i pico.
Anem trobant túnels d'aquests pels quals passar pel costat, cap problema,
però just aquest,
sembla que no té camí pel costat.
Per tant, doncs passaré per dintre del túnel.
No és tan dramàtic com el túnel de la mort.
Sembla que l'espai que hi ha en aquesta plataforma és més gran
i, bé, el túnel és molt més petit, no hi ha gasos, no hi ha aigua.
Molt millor, tu.
Molt millor.
He parat aquí a menjar una mica de pa amb formatge.
Una mica de bastanta calma avui.
I m'ha donat per tornar a buscar a veure si trobava l'adaptador del Garmin.
I sí.
Ostres, això és millor que em vingui algú i em regali tres sopars, saps?
O em regali 100 euros.
L'alegria és màxima quan trobes alguna cosa que has perdut.
On estava?
On havia d'estar.
On el poso sempre.
I mira que he buscat dues vegades.
He buidat gairebé la bossa aquesta estanca que porto amb l'electrònica
i no l'havia trobat.
I estava allà.
No ho entenc.
Bueno, doncs perfecte.
Avui ho he gravat amb l'estrava del mòbil, per això no amb el Garmin.
Per tant, avui al final no tindreu el gràfic aquell.
Que bé, tu. Genial.
La una i mitja he arribat a un restaurant que hi havia per aquí.
Una Coca-Cola sencera.
Amb aquest got.
He demanat un got i m'han portat això.
I una amanida i carn.
Bueno, és lo que hi ha, no?
És lo que hi ha.
Puc carregar.
Puc descansar una mica.
Fa bastanta calor.
Ja sí que es nota.
La baixada duixant bé i a calor.
No hi ha ventilació.
No veuran les finestres.
Estic cansat, eh?
Les quatre i mitja segueixo avançant.
Que no tinc les dades del rellotge, no sé molt bé quants quilòmetres porto.
Crec que vint i llargs.
O tampoc posaria la mà al foc.
Bueno, com veieu, estem en una vall bastant estreta.
Bastant tancada amb les muntanyes altes.
Des de fa vint minuts ja no tenim sol.
I potser ja no torno a tenir sol durant tot el dia.
Això, com a mínim, és bo.
Lo dolent.
Ja he estat veient aquests últims dies que és un país dur, eh, aquest?
És un país molt maco, la gent molt hospitalària, les muntanyes.
Però és dur viatjar per aquí, eh?
Perquè els bars, restaurants, són escassos.
Els estandards de neteja són baixos.
O sigui, avui on he estat la taula estava bruta, bastant bruta.
I la safata on m'han portat el pa tenia com bastanta ronyes, saps?
Dius, home, això els mínims.
No sé, uns mínims, no?
Evidentment no hi ha tasses enlloc de Butterdick.
És un país que has d'estar acostumat a cert disconfort per venir aquí, eh?
Espero que a Doshanbe, bueno, segur que a Doshanbe trobareu una habitació decent.
I si no, ja la buscaré i la pagaré per estar aquests dies.
Descansaran dos, en principi.
És a dir, faré un dia de descans i arribaré demà.
Demà no hi haurà vídeo, perquè serà un tram petit de 15-20 km, jo crec, fins a Doshanbe.
Jo crec que no val la pena.
I el dia següent, com no caminaré, tampoc hi haurà vídeo.
Llavors, bueno, dos dies sense vídeo.
Seran els dos dies amb un cert confort, perquè és una ciutat gran tal, que ja no tindré fins a...
La Xina no sé com serà.
Jo crec que potser sí, però potser ja fins a Islamabad, saps?
Vull dir, molt de temps.
I tinc ganes de menjar, menjar occidental.
Una burger, una pizza, encara que una pizza bona crec que no la trobaré, però una burger, alguna cosa així.
Perquè estaré molt de temps menjant molt de plof i altres coses que estan bé, estan bé.
Però, home, vull una mica de varietat, també.
Bueno, doncs ja et dic.
Avui acamparé.
Segueixo encara unes dues hores i mitja.
Aquí, una mansió gegant.
Un edifici gegant a mig construir.
Una piscina, allà.
Gegant, això he dit que és.
Obro el mapi i posa.
Palau presidencial... No.
...del Govern de la República de Tajikistan.
Bueno, no gravaré en detall, malauradament, per vosaltres.
Pel que pugui passar, perquè potser està prohibit.
Però sí que darrere d'aquests arbres hi ha unes quantes mansions.
Són les 6.40.
I en aquesta part de la vall, al contrari que tota la resta que porto baixant,
comença a haver-hi bastantes cases.
I cases de rics.
De rics... Tajiks, com podeu veure aquí darrere.
Doncs hi ha aquest tipus de mansions.
No totes són així tan bèsties.
Però sí, bastantes. Llavors...
Doncs no hi ha tantes oportunitats per acampar, pel que he vist.
Ara, vist aquí, veieu aquesta entrada aquí?
Aquí hi ha una espècie de lloc més o menys pla, aquí.
Podria posar la tenda.
No podria agafar aigua del riu, probablement, perquè...
Bueno, ja ho veuríem.
El que passa és que hi ha una cabana on he vist que hi ha un home assegut.
Vaig a preguntar-li a veure si hi ha cap problema.
I acabaria així el dia d'avui.
16.40.
Podria caminar 20 minuts més, però...
A veure si em deixa.
Camping? Yes. Problem? No.
Tot bé. Rahmat. Somriures.
I genial.
Bueno, doncs, darrere ha estat la cabana aquesta.
Barraca, meines.
Aquí està el riu, el que passa és que hi ha un mur.
Llavors que no puc baixar a recollir.
I aquí és el lloc on deia...
Home, no sé si es veu, no és molt...
Herba idíl·lica, no?
Què va.
Però aquí és com bastant pla.
Bueno.
Ja.
Regular, eh? Estic per buscar un altre lloc. No m'acaba de...
I allà, lo seu, a veure, seria poder baixar...
Per agafar aigua.
Per rentar-me les cames, perquè... No.
No, no. No puc baixar aquí, no.
No. No, no, no.
Busco un altre lloc, perquè encara tinc temps, eh?
Si no em puc rentar és bastant fastigós, eh? Avui estic bastant brut.
Poder accedir al riu per rentar-me serà molt difícil, però...
Just aquí hi havia un market, he comprat una aigua amb gas, que era l'única que tenia.
Això em servirà com a mínim, crec, que amb l'aigua que tingui això...
Per rentar-me una mica les cames. I aquí hi ha una gran esplanada.
Bueno, gran. Una mica d'esplanada, on veig que hi ha uns joves.
Però crec que em puc posar per aquí.
Sí. Hi ha una tanca, com podeu veure, però està oberta.
Va.
Jo crec que sí. Jo crec que... Algú ho trobarem per aquí.
Ai, que no us he posat context. Al final no m'he quedat en aquell lloc.
Se m'havia oblidat de dir-vos-ho. No. He marxat.
Doncs han marxat els nois ja, estaven pescant.
Molts simpàtics, no parlen anglès, però han dit sí, sí, camping, camping.
Molts simpàtics i poc més.
Tenim una mansió allà al darrere, com podeu veure.
Però jo imagino que estarà buida, perquè si no, no té sentit que el tros aquest de terreny estigui obert a qualsevol persona, no?
Tampoc veig llum.
Bueno.
Els cotxes que van cap al sud, que són els que estan a aquesta banda,
per uns arbres que hi ha aquí, doncs no em veuen, això és bo.
I els que van cap al nord, com que estan a l'altra banda, en principi tampoc em podrien veure.
Que tampoc hauria de passar res, no? Però per si a cas.
Bueno. Avui 36 km, només.
Bastant, bastant poc.
Tenint en compte que era baixada.
Sí, sí. Contrasta amb ahir, no? Que un dia va ser bastant dur i vaig ser molts km.
Suposo que per això, perquè estava cansat, n'he fet menys, no?
Però sí, sí, avui...
Això és una competició, això, d'acord?
Però si ho fos, seria bastant patètic.
Però bé, ja està.
Al final, demà hauré de fer bastants km per arribar a Dushanbe.
No serà una tapeta petita.
Però bueno, tampoc la gravaré.
Un cafè.
He parlat amb 5 persones, els lituans dels motociclistes, ningú més.
M'he saludat amb molta gent, però parlar amb ningú...
Refrescos, 4.
I m'he gastat 10 euros.
7 del dinar i 3 de...
Altres compres, diverses.
Molt bé.
Fa molt de temps que no fem això, així que va tocant.
Avui que el vídeo és una mica més curt.
Foguera.
A veure, si me'n recordo de les preguntes.
Primera pregunta.
Quin és el repte de Tadjikistan?
Doncs...
Mira, he estat pensant i no se m'ha corregut res.
El començarem després de Dushanbe.
Seria el proper dia, el proper vídeo.
Doncs...
Ja començarem amb el repte de Tadjikistan.
Que us demano que...
Que us demano que em doneu suggerències.
Doneu-li una mica el coco.
Una cosa que sigui original, divertida...
Que no sigui fer cada dia, perquè aquestes són complicades.
No sé, doneu-me idees.
A veure què pot ser.
Què més?
Em pregunten per les sabatilles.
Ah, què tal?
Bueno, com sabeu, em vaig canviar de sabatilles.
Em vaig comprar aquesta segona mà a Tbilisi.
Les Hookah Speedgoat 3.
I què tal?
Bé...
L'atracció...
Increïble.
No m'he relliscat cap vegada.
I això que he anat per llocs molt costaruts i amb grava,
que sempre això rellisca bastant.
Súper bé.
Sí que és veritat que...
Crec que jo tinc un problema que...
El teu dret...
Crec que...
La...
El...
Com que...
Trapitjo cap a l'interior, no?
Això té un nom, que és pronador-sopinador.
No sé quin dels dos és.
Llavors, a vegades, si no me la...
Si no me la deixo...
Si no me la lligo molt bé, em causa una mica de molèstia.
No és dolor, però una mica de molèstia a una zona de la planta.
Però bueno, això és qüestió de lligar-me-la bé.
Ficar la plantilla perfecta.
I llavors...
Llavors sí que bé.
Amb les Icebook no tenia aquest problema.
Amb les Icebook sempre eren còmodes.
Mai van ser incòmodes.
Però bueno.
Però bé, bé.
Estic...
Estic satisfet.
A veure com...
Com la durabilitat...
De moment...
Bueno.
El taco està...
Està molt bé.
Després em pregunten per la motxilla.
Perquè hem vist alguns forats.
Sí.
Té alguns forats.
Aquí us ensenyo un.
Però també té algun altre al lateral a les malles.
Això és pels objectes punxeguts.
Els pals de la tenda, doncs, a vegades els he ficat ací a saco i s'ha rajat.
Els forats no creixen especialment.
O sigui, no es fan molt més grans.
Però sí.
Són forats...
Suposo que es poden cosir.
S'ha de posar a fer-ho.
Lo de cosir.
Però...
Bueno.
Ja...
Quan sigui dramàtic ja ho faré.
Però per la resta...
La motxilla...
Està perfecta.
Una mica bruta, potser.
Però...
La resta bé.
Però sí que és veritat que les malles aquestes...
Hi fan una mica de mal efecte, no?
Tenir la motxilla forada.
Però...
Bueno.
Funciona.
La funcionalitat és perfecta.
I em pregunten també si té el nyigui-nyogui.
A veure.
Rarament jo vaig tant en silenci com per escoltar el nyigui-nyogui.
Però algun cop que he anat...
Algún cop que he anat...
Hi ha hagut molt de silenci, sí que he escoltat de tant en quant, no sempre, però de tant
en quant he escoltat un i-o-i-o.
Sí.
A la motxilla.
I...
És molest perquè, clar, tu en aquells moments que ets en silenci, vols gaudir del silenci.
I molesta molt aquest soroll.
Però la majoria de temps, com o portes els auriculars o hi ha molt de soroll, doncs no
ho notes.
Però...
Sí.
Les ospre i...
Moltes tenen aquest problema.
Sí.
Em pregunten què és el que he odiat més, si les gestions o no sé què...
O els gossos, diu?
No, no me'n recordo què és el comentari, però bueno.
El que més he odiat és quan perdo algo.
Quan perdo algo és...
És el pitjor.
Bueno, ja us ho dic sempre que perdo algo, sobretot quan és algo important.
Fatal.
Què més?
Quines preguntes més hi havia?
A veure si me'n recordo.
Les estrelles.
Sí.
He vist el cel estrellat.
No ho he comentat perquè, clar, com és algo que no puc ensenyar...
Fatal.
Sí.
És algo que passa quan estic acampat, que normalment mai gravo ni explico res, doncs
no ho he comentat, no?
Però aquells dies no hi ha lluna o la lluna no surt bé o no les veu, no sé què, hi ha
molta foscor, a més, a dalt de les muntanyes encara més, i he vist un cel brutal.
D'aquell que es veu la Via Làctea...
Sí.
I jo que no porto ulleres, eh?
Encara no veig tan bé.
O sigui, jo sóc un pèl miop i hauria de portar unes ulleres, no amb gaires dioptries, però
sí.
I sí, sí.
Es veu la franja aquesta...
Si algú sap com fer fotos, astrofotografia, amb un Samsung Galaxy, que ho sàpiga, sisplau.
O sigui, que m'avisi i que m'ho expliqui, però que ho sàpiga fer.
No que ho busqui a l'IA i em diu, mira, l'IA o aquest vídeo diu que s'ha de fer així.
No.
Algú que sàpiga fer-ho, de veritat, i que surti bé, sisplau que m'escrigui i ho faig.
Jo ho vaig intentar amb el mòbil anterior, el S22 Plus, i no queden tan bé com quan
tenia el Google Play.
Va ser el Pixel 5, que va ser el mòbil anterior.
Amb aquell les fotos nocturnes quedaven...
I eren brutals.
Però amb el Samsung Galaxy S22 no ha acabat de sortir bé.
I amb l'S24 Plus, que és el que tinc ara, doncs no ho he provat, la veritat, però podria
provar-ho.
Doncs ja està.
He mirat i aquestes eren les cinc preguntes.
N'hi havia més, però aquestes eren les que em semblen més interessants i les que també
es repetien més.
Gaudiu del pont del 15 d'agost i ens veiem a la tornada.
Tchau!